thank you
[Music]
and everybody we are back to another
awesome episode of the careful void the
care pool careful and girl or lady or
whatever she identifies with wow that's
pretty good what do you identify with
wow identify as she her Brecken oh oh
yeah
all right so uh we have Kristen here
what's up Kristen hey guys how's it
going good good we were just talking
about how you know Bart's on the
Spectrum are you really I am officially
he's loved on the Spectrum when I was in
junior high I got diagnosed with uh ADHD
and uh OCD when and how did that come
about like was there already
complications and your parents are like
there's something wrong with this
[ __ ] we need to go get them
checked out the school did that but you
know what's funny is the school when you
hear those two things right ADHD and OCD
yeah
something that that together well it's
kind of like Fire and Ice it doesn't
you're very organized but at the same
time you can't pay attention that that
is that is kind of paradoxical yeah yeah
so I got it into a lot of trouble
um in all of my schooling years and
shout outs to Mr Tarpley at Carmenita
middle school or Junior High known as
Junior High
um but he was the assistant principal
and he was the only one that believed in
me so um we had two principles and they
would both always so like as a normal
student you actually don't know what
your school district's office looks like
right because you just go to school and
you go home and if you even get
suspended or expelled it's generally
from your school
so you are a real big Troublemaker if
you are going to the school district's
office all the time because it's beyond
the control of the school and I went
there constantly as a kid and so my uh
my principal would always try to get me
expelled try to get me sent to the other
schools and stuff and uh Mr Tarpley
really believed in me because he just
felt like I was either like a mismanaged
kid or I was a lost kid or something he
felt like I was smart and so I think one
of the things that he did to try to like
keep me at school is to show that I'm
actually smart and so he hired a um like
a counselor of some sort like the
district psychologist counselor and so
we did like a whole series of tests for
a whole week one of them was an IQ test
and then the other one was just like
observing me in class and stuff like
that cater just to you just for me yeah
and then they he's a science experiment
I guess and then they they diagnosed me
with ADHD and OCD and the OCD is more of
the
um like obsessive part so I don't have
the like this needs to be like this
but it's more of like extreme impulse or
if you're like obsessive about like
whooping Fool's ass it could be or like
if I if I get so I'm either like really
distracted all the time or I'm [ __ ]
zoned in like no happier that just
sounds like ADHD like in a portal that
just sounds like ADHD like not the OCD
part but like that ADHD has the ability
to focus when they're really on a high
frequency meaning like
um when you're when you're just like
um adrenaline rush or like you have to
um do something that's like when you're
in the zone for sports or whatever
apparently that's the talent for people
with ADHD
then you have that Ultra Focus yeah but
that's what they uh diagnosed me as and
then so as a kid I think you kind of
hear things and it almost sounds like a
crutch but then later on you find all
these like other like artists or other
people that you kind of look up to and
everyone kind of had a rough upbringing
too because like the way the
institutions are set up it's made to be
like a factory right like all these kids
come in and they go first second third
grade all up to senior and they push
them out into society so for a thing to
be a smooth working Factory you want
like squares to go in squares triangles
to go into triangles but then if you're
a weird shape tooth while octagon yeah
I'm an octagon or a [ __ ] heart-shaped
who taught you off the go and it's hard
to like Place me in this system so I
probably would have done way better like
homeschooled or to more Liberal Liberal
Arts type of school
um but I had like these tendencies that
were really rough around the edges for a
typical school and I don't think I
really even was able to tap into the
because I think everything kind of has
like a pro and a con the con is I didn't
fit in school but I think it also made
me a very creative person I probably
didn't really tap into that until like
JK days what does it feel like to be
diagnosed uh as like a middle school kid
because I I definitely like have seen
you know kids get diagnosed when they're
younger when they maybe don't have like
the intellect to like comprehend exactly
what that is do you feel like at that
age especially being in junior high
already it's like having a counselor or
professional coming be like this is like
what you have like did that
what would that feel like for you I
think I was just like so
I don't know if it affected me because I
also think like
um I also did a follow-up with
medication did they like medication so
they recommended it
um because I was too crazy and uh but my
mom's like super holistic it's just like
yeah we're gonna go [ __ ] bird's nest
we're gonna go boil some [ __ ] wasps
aren't you glad she did that I'm so glad
I'm so glad my parents didn't medicate
me either oh that's what it comes up
they just abused me instead and I would
much rather take an ass beating than a
[ __ ] Adderall pill yeah cause that's
the problem too like with medications
and they don't test for like or they
don't have longitudinal studies right
like decades at a time
they they just go oh we tested this for
two years and it seems like it works or
whatever right but then now we have
studies that show people generally grow
out of ADHD so it's just a period of
time so like now like I probably still
have it a little bit but it's not
affecting me from shooting 20 videos in
a row you know what I mean whereas I
think if you just look at Super like uh
zoomed in and you're like well you take
all these medications it can [ __ ] kids
up that's what I was gonna say because
if you're if you put a kid on medication
then their brain gets wired and you see
that and then you try to take them off
and that's when like the problems are
going to continue I feel like almost
um a lot of people are probably
undiagnosed especially with like ADHD
and those types of things just because
it is very very common but um you know
some people are obviously different on
the spectrum of those it's only a
problem I think because like you said
the system the way that it works it's
like a factory right so then it's an
issue because you can't pay attention
and learn and be a part of the program
system because it's the system if we
were jungle boys and we were out there
hunting living life that way it's not a
problem at all yeah so it's so the
concept in in mental health it's a very
new it's a it's this like it's only
recently that people started going to
therapy even understanding what these
labels are or whatever but um just the
label in itself
when a bunch of idiots get a hold of a
concept like that then they can use it
in really stupid ways like oh I have
ADHD therefore I am this way or whatever
like and they make it's a horoscope or
something [ __ ] horoscope dude or it
becomes a part of their identity yeah
I'm depressed that's why I'm this way
and this one it's like dude you're
talking about it like you're an Aries or
some [ __ ] or a cancer like I'm sad all
the time because it's not what it is
yeah it's a slippery slope like not
working towards getting better at the
problem just being like Oh I identify as
this now so I'm just gonna kind of tap
into It Adele makes a bunch of sad songs
you know yeah make some songs and then
also there's the stigma and stain that
you get once you're diagnosed with
something then all of a sudden oh I feel
less than because I am disabled or
whatever and I'm like that's the
weirdest thing in Psychology too and um
you know I I when I majored in
Psychology in one of my classes
it was one of the most interesting
professors because he was like you know
the more I study psychology and the more
I realized I don't know anything about
psychology and then I was like and
everyone's like what and he goes yeah
you're going to waste your time here
because I had a clinic he was or like he
goes I got my bachelor's and he goes I
don't know enough maybe I'll get my
masters and he goes I still don't know
enough he goes maybe I'll get my PhD
maybe I'll start
um and start uh uh uh I'll you know
build my own clinic and then I'll you
know be a therapist and do all that
stuff right and he goes and after all
this experience he goes I still don't
understand the human brain and he goes
what I realized is the how we're trained
and the this book the DSM whatever he
goes I can label anybody here with any
of these diseases and then I can
prescribe you medicine and then he goes
That's all this is it's just how do I
label you this something in the book and
then prescribe you medicine to this book
and have you keep coming back to my
therapy sessions and he goes That's the
business so he's like do you really want
to learn about mental health conditions
and things like that or do you want to
sustain your customer base and then I
was like damn that's [ __ ] crazy and
he goes yeah but I'm a professor and I
want to do research and I do want to
find groundbreaking things about the
human mind and he goes but that's not
the way that they teach you like if they
teach you to be a part of this business
and the business is how do I prescribe
drugs and how do I keep you coming back
to my therapy sessions and I'm like damn
that's just like modern medicine though
that's Dark As [ __ ] pal I mean it's
happening though so my nephew my
sister's son um he's autistic he's eight
years old he's not like super super high
on the Spectrum but he definitely is you
can tell some things a little bit off
with him but
um like you said with the system you
know they diagnosed him my sister was
like I'm not going to do medication or
anything what are some of the things
that are off
um social cues uh kind of just like
acting out a little bit like he he
struggles in those settings you know the
school
um definitely reaches out he's in a
regular school but you know the teachers
are like you know he's acting out with
this or like sometimes he's saying like
certain things he kind of doesn't really
know right from wrong but he's a really
really good kid but I feel like the
system
is kind of putting that as a negative
towards him but he's also incredibly
smart I mean that happens with a lot of
autistic people when he was three four
years old he could play Monopoly and he
wanted to be the banker he knew money he
knew how to do yeah [ __ ] when he was
like three or four he's so so yeah
you're [ __ ] done I can't even do that
now he's so good at video games and
understanding technology but instead of
my sister highlights it but the system
is kind of um bringing him down a little
bit so it's kind of interesting to see
how it's directly affecting you know
someone in my family but you know he's a
great kid and he'll probably be super
successful there's a lot of people that
have done great things that you know are
on the Spectrum or something but I feel
like it's just how the approach yeah
that's the part that sucks because like
I think most people examine things
at like a one-year phase or one-year
Journey at a time so for most parents
that are probably really busy they'd be
like oh [ __ ] it's so hard to like uh
deal with an autistic kid here's some
medication because then that makes life
that helps yeah rather than looking at
things as an 18-year Journey like this
is all part of it it's supposed to be
like this it's okay and then seeing what
happens there and then if they need
medication then maybe we'll give them
medication if they need to be a part of
society but that's something I was super
grateful for when my mom was so against
medicine that it was it's now it's a
part of me where it's like I'm not
getting arrested all the time or
whatever you just kind of grew out of
that you know yeah it's just not the
norm
um my sister hasn't told her son yet I
mean he's eight now um she hasn't told
them that he's autistic just because she
doesn't want him to mentally have that
label and think that he's different and
then you know like we were talking about
kind of fall into that self-sabotaging
like I'm different I'm never gonna be
good enough
um I don't know I wonder like at what
age you know you kind of have that
conversation is he being homeschooled no
she's going to regular school but he's
it's starting to notice that he's
standing out from the other kids yeah my
kid taika played with a kid that had
autism on the playground and uh the
parents told told me about hey our kid
has autism and I'm like oh like how does
that like manifest and he goes um he's a
little bit more impulsive and could get
a little bit violent but it does not
come out of any bad like intentions and
um I think like be like so is my kid
don't worry
and then um but then I saw the real
difference so like Taiko and him was
kind of like wrestling and then he was
um
his parent told me like uh my kid wants
to like always like pick up kids and
throw them down
that's completely cool because my kid
takes Jiu Jitsu and so he'll like he
knows how to break fall like he'll know
how to break fall it's it's completely
fine so I watch him and he just wants to
constantly like throw tiger on the
ground I would keep checking I'm talking
okay okay if you don't like it let me
know or let him know and he was
completely cool with it and then when he
said uh
um you told him to come here and go say
we have to go home now it's getting dark
the kid was like what hi at the mom but
not out of like
um
like rebelliousness but just really
intense like sometimes they just don't
understand and they have a lot of
feelings and since they don't have the
social cues they can't really
communicate it's crazy I was like whoa
[ __ ] and it just was just like every
like if we were how we acted were like
notes on a piano the uh the other kid
was more like
very loud and expressive I used to coach
just one kid who was autistic but he
could he if you didn't know he was
autistic you would think he was just the
normal kid he's like high functioning
autism exactly exactly but like so much
of his messaging from his mother and his
parents was like he's autistic he's
autistic he's autistic so it became a
label form yeah and it became like
almost like a crutch so anytime you felt
like any type of frustration he'd always
be like but I'm autistic I can't do this
blah blah blah but you realize it's like
it's not like you can't do anything else
that the other kids could do it's like
you guys could all do it but so much of
it was like a bear in his brain where he
just would just anytime he felt like
some like he hit a wall or something he
would just be like it's because I'm
autistic he throws [ __ ] arms up in
here but he was such a good kid and he's
such a bright kid and now he's he's like
I think 18 19. he's like he's like a
music producer he's doing good and he's
killing it like he and he's he wouldn't
even [ __ ] know I feel like it's just
the development my sister also struggles
with
um sometimes she doesn't like to tell
the other parents of kids that he's
hanging out with that he's autistic
because she's coming to situations where
she tells them that he's autistic and
then they kind of like hey kids you know
that's [ __ ] up yeah you're so [ __ ]
up and my sister's like gone off on
people because he's a great kid it's
just I feel like people need to
understand it a little bit more and like
the development of a child with autism
or with a disorder what they go through
and how to deal with it yeah
it's so [ __ ] up let's get out of here
man oh my God the kid's like he's like
what I was hiking with um Ken and a
couple of friends you know Ian Canyon
there's this waterfall at the end and so
we like to go and like maybe jump in the
waterfall or whatever and then
um there was this like Father and Son
there the sun was like a six foot
massive baby right like like a big big
kid right and I think he had Down
syndrome or something like that but his
his dad was pretty you know he was he
was Asian he was probably like the song
was probably in his 30s and then the dad
was maybe like in his
um 70s or something and and he was like
trying to get him to get out of the
water and then everyone knew like this
this guy had doubts or something and and
um his dad was just so embarrassed he
goes I'm so sorry he's a [ __ ] he's a
soul [ __ ] I'm so sorry and he's
trying to get him out and we're like no
it's cool it's cool he's having fun and
he goes I need to go home he doesn't
want to go out and he's like panicking
right so we're just sitting there we're
eating and then he's looking at he goes
Apple like that and then he's looking at
he goes can my son have a apple he's so
[ __ ] and then I'm all like yeah you
had to keep calling him that dude like
sure why do you have to say that every
single time like I don't understand but
like the look in the Dad's face is like
he was like he didn't know what to do
yeah like it's helpless and his son was
huge he was like like yeah he was like a
football player like a big boy and the
funny thing is like his shirt was too
small so he had a little belly like he
looked like a big toddler because his
pants was tied probably I'll glue his
clothes really fast yeah and he was just
sitting there like you know the the way
that the river is and then I mean the
waterfall is and there's that little
pool yeah and he liked to be in the
little pool and he had like a little
raincoat with a hat and [ __ ] and then
like he was just having a good time he
didn't want to leave
and then when he he finally came out to
get an apple right so we're eating
apples we gave him one and then he he's
like eating and he starts walking toward
the waterfall again and his dad's trying
to get him out and I'm like damn I don't
know how you're gonna get him out there
but the whole time you're it's like it
was just like the dad is so embarrassed
and everyone got it like they're like
yeah we know man it's not a big deal and
then he felt like he was bothering
everybody he felt like such a like
burden and I'm like dude he's just
having a good time just chilling in the
water like everyone doesn't feel like
yeah it's not a big deal yeah but you
know also never know when it was a big
deal somewhere else and some other
bystanders were not as nice you know
what I mean
yeah so but read the room though huh
read the film read the waterfalls Joe's
a cool guy Joe loves the water dude it
felt like it feel like um like Kung Fu
Panda in the store like a little old man
with a kung fu
I don't know have you guys actually been
diagnosed diagnosed though or like I've
never been diagnosed diagnosed but my um
friend she is uh she specializes she's a
psychiatrist and she specializes in
children with ADHD and she looked at you
and she was like something clearly
we've been friends since high school she
remembers me in class I don't remember
most of my years because it was just so
much impulsiveness I don't have much of
a good memory
and then I recently read this book
called The ADHD advantage and then
there's a survey in there and then
they're like yeah if you have like six
out of ten
in this little questionnaire you
probably have some you know you fall
within the spectrum of ADHD and I was 10
out of 10 and then I was telling her all
these things like Hey do you remember me
in high school and then like I know you
specialize in children with this stuff
and I've never been diagnosed but what
do you think she goes no you clearly got
it and then she goes would you like to
talk to my students
we have a recovered ADHD
he owns a drink store now I know this is
a high functioning one would you like to
talk to my students still making drinks
in under a minute we were all worried
for you in high school we didn't know
how you were gonna turn out that's
pretty good yeah so if you guys
um that haven't been diagnosed or
something if you were diagnosed today
because I feel like everyone has a
little bit something nobody's brain is
like perfect
um I think everyone is on the Spencer I
mean everyone's on the spectrum of
something you know what I mean but if
someone's like Ryan uh you're autistic
that's why you're so good at like so
many things
um would you change your perspective or
no you live fine I'm I don't know
because I'm a firm believer on like I
think a lot of people sort of uh
don't realize how much power big Pharma
has over making up new [ __ ] and I think
a lot of that is like if there's a
medicine to go along with it that they
can sell you I think you should kind of
think about how legit that really is
yeah
I don't know like do your thing Anthony
do your thing because I don't feel like
any of these things are advantages or
disadvantages like we already know
across the board so many people that
have had ADHD or add or any of those
things and a ton of them are fine even
depression sure like everyone gets
depressed you can manage and that's just
lifestyle based that's not really
medicine based and I don't know I feel
like when something is pushed that hard
and that connected to socioeconomics and
Pharma then I'm like well that's the
[ __ ] formula right there it's true
when somebody's like yo I'm depressed
I'm like oh damn that sucks when
somebody's like I'm depressed and I'm
taking antidepressants I'm like you're
[ __ ] yeah like you are [ __ ] right
the most depressed people I ever met
that went on anti have had the worst
downfall yeah it did not come back I
feel like medicine comes in handy if you
got to the point you're trying to work
through everything and you're about to
have like some psychotic break or your
brain physically can't be in Balance
there's gonna be consequences then look
to medicine is potentially an option but
other than that obviously Bart's mom
yeah dude she gets that I think that's
it that's a good snails and [ __ ] thanks
to holistic treatments and kind of like
Asian medicine where these kind of home
remedy things that sort of even if they
don't [ __ ] work it saved our asses
from real [ __ ] going wrong even if they
don't work Ryan yeah Placebo style but
that it's a good diversion from having
to take something that could alter your
brain chemistry for life
it's like cool I do think that a lot of
the stress that humans are experiencing
now it's because we're not living
naturally to how we've been evolved to
live for so long right so then your
brain is is just like out of balance
because we're sleep deprived we're
always staring at a screen you're not
moving your body you're probably not
drinking enough water you're not seeing
the sun you're not sleeping you know
you're not totally describing this room
dude I do all those things dog so the
thing is like when people are feeling
for hours a little bit of stress or
whatever I always say hey are all these
things done first and foremost and No
One Believes that that can make any
change they're in disbelief that it's
that simple
my life
yeah
sometimes you just need to sleep because
you haven't slept in seven days go
outside just go maybe sleep yeah maybe
if you woke up in the morning and then
went to sleep at night your body you
know the physical body does affect what
what happens to yourself mentally
like if you're constantly in physical
pain that's going to depress you and
then so it's all these subtle things
right if you're like slowly like if
you're not eating enough if like you're
you know waking up at like 4 P.M and
going to sleep at 3 A.M and then you're
playing games or on in front of a screen
if you're not walking if you're not
moving if you're not doing anything like
that shit's gonna [ __ ] you up so hard
and then all of a sudden you're
wondering why you're depressed it's like
well maybe because you're living like a
cancer patient and then your body's not
moving I'm not getting a Make-a-Wish
thing though yeah dude I don't get to
meet John Cena at the end of the day
I would love you John Cena John Cena